pants come for us my name is Pippa today
I have some very very very exciting news
you may have noticed recently my videos
have been up kind of late I've been been
slacking off but there's a reason for it
it's all been leading up to something
beautiful as you may or may not know
recently I was in Japan where we
actually secretly finished filming this
project so with the help of Warner
Brothers legendary paramount and Singh
Corp Studios I am very proud to finally
announce the PewDiePie movie it stars me
of course
Edgar is gonna be an in it a lot of my
YouTube friends Mark Jack uh Ken
keemstar the trailer that's gonna be up
tomorrow but I am allowed to show a
little teaser part which I'm really
really really excited about this really
means a lot to me and I really hope you
boys are gonna like it
so here it is I'm so nervous
Edgar we have to save our friends dead I
don't have to reach my perspective
around
I'm Finnish Murphy's Law Murphy's Law is
up mr. surface latest passive
there was new iPhones vitamin D dostala'
this comma talk